en este vídeo quiero tratar acerca de
puras gráficas de funciones cuadráticas
y para eso tengo estos planos calzados
que estoy dibujando a la derecha sin
embargo quiero repasar algo que vimos en
el vídeo pasado en el cual cometió un
pequeño error y ya no lo puede corregir
de youtube y por lo tanto se quedó este
error ahí en el vídeo cuando yo ponía
que tenía algo de la forma fx más que
que multiplicaba hay x + j se acuerdan
en el vídeo pasado lo vimos y esto me
quedaba de resultado f h x cuadrada efe
h xvii x x xx cuadrada y justo aquí
estaba mi error porque no puse este
cuadrado se me olvidó perdón pero no
estaba muy despistado a la vez pasada y
no pues este cuadrado y después me
quedaba efe por x por j quedaba el pj x
y después g por h por x me quedara g h x
y por último me quedaba gj se acuerdan
esto lo habíamos visto en el vídeo
pasado y el vídeo pasado omití este
cuadrado que estaba aquí y por lo tanto
pues parece que no era una función
cuadrática prende efecto
la función cuadrática y ahora que me doy
cuenta de mi error quiero compartirlos y
poner un poco de cara de pena porque
olvidé este cuadrado pero bueno no es el
tema de esta ocasión en esta ocasión
quiero ver gráficas de puras funciones
cuadráticas cómo se grafican funciones
cuadráticas algo como por este estilo
supongamos que yo tengo una función que
es igual a que es cuadrada menos 2 x
menos 8 y bueno lo primero que quiero
que te des cuenta es que aquí tenemos
una función que es cuadrática tenemos x
cuadrada menos 2 x menos 8 por lo tanto
mi gráfica no va a ser una línea recta
que nos va a salir de gráfica de esta
función bueno nos va a salir algo de
este estilo y bueno el menú a seguir va
a ser el siguiente lo que voy a buscar
son las intersecciones con el eje de las
equis y después voy a encontrar el
vértice ya vas a ver lo que es el
vértice en un segundo antes lo que
quiero ver es cómo se actualiza esta
expresión y voy a buscar dos números que
multiplicados me den menos 8 y que
sumados me den menos 2 y creo que
funciona con menos 4 y 2 positivos menos
4 por 2 me da menos 8
los 42 me da menos 2x perfecto por lo
tanto esto se puede factorizar como x
menos 4 que multiplica a x + 2 a x + 2 y
bueno lo primero que voy a hacer es
buscar cuáles son las intersecciones con
el eje de las x y para esto voy a buscar
los valores de x tales que lleva al ga 0
porque si te das cuenta cuando
interceptamos al eje de las x lo que
estamos diciendo es que vale 0 no
estamos subiendo nada lo único que
estamos haciendo es buscando valores de
x por lo tanto voy a hacer esta función
igual a 0 0 es igual a x menos 4 x x + 2
y esto ya lo habíamos visto si teníamos
dos binomios multiplicándose que eran
iguales a cero queríamos decir que el
primero es 0 o el segundo es 0 o x menos
4 es igual a cero o en su lado caso x +
2 es igual a 0 y bueno en el primero me
queda que x es igual a 4 paso del otro
lado del 4 sumando y en el otro caso me
queda que x es igual a menos 2 si restó
menos dos de los dos lados me queda que
x es igual a menos 2 y ya tengo mis dos
raíces de esta ecuación o ya tengo mis
dos valores para
cuál es esta ecuación se hace 0 o dicho
de otra manera ya encontré aquellas
valores o mejor aún aquellos puntos en
donde interceptamos al eje de las x el
40 y el menos 20 así que vamos a
graficar los así que déjenme tomar un
color un poco más fuerte para graficar
esta función y me va a quedar los puntos
40 que es este de aquí y menos 20 que va
a ser este de por acá menos uno menos 20
muy bien entonces por aquí va a pasar mi
parábola y más aún por aquí intersecta
mi parábola al eje de las x ahora a
continuación que quiero pensar es cuánto
vale el valor del vértice de mi parábola
porque el vértice de mi parábola
curiosamente tienen como valor en x al
punto medio entre estos dos puntos y que
esas vértices de una parábola bueno
alguna vez vimos que todas las funciones
cuadráticas se veían de esta forma estas
son parábolas y de esta que estoy
dibujando aquí es su vértice su vértice
es su valor más pequeño es decir el
mínimo de esta función o en su dado caso
su vez eso el valor más grande esta
función
es un máximo de esta función y estas dos
son para abu las son parábolas porque
son las gráficas que nos quedan al
graficar ecuaciones cuadráticas siempre
que tengamos una ecuación cuadrática
como ésta nos va a quedar una parábola y
entonces fíjate bien si nosotros
interceptamos aquí en el eje de las x
siempre nos va a quedar el vértice en
medio de estos dos valores de x o de
otra manera el punto medio pensado en x
va a ser aquel punto al cual va a
corresponder mi x entonces vamos a
calcular la x del vértice quien va a ser
xy déjame ponerlo mejor si si así lo voy
a poner x del vértice x del vértice es
igual a 4 menos 2 entre 2 es decir el
punto medio en x entre estos dos valores
que habíamos sacado cuando nosotros
interceptamos con el eje del sx4 más
menos 2 entre 2 me queda 14 menos 12 2 2
entre 12 es 1 entonces cuando x vale 1
nosotros tenemos nuestro vértice ahora
sería muy bueno saber cuánto vale el
valor de nuestro vértice y bueno vamos a
sustituir en nuestra ocasión que tenemos
aquí arriba
1 - 2 - 8 porque es un al cuadrado menos
2 por 1 menos 8 y 1 - 2 - 1 - 18 menos 9
y entonces ya tengo el punto de 1000
vértice así que el punto 1 menos 9 es el
punto del vértice de mi parábola uno
coma menos 9 - 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 menos 6
- 7 menos 8 menos 9 estamos parados aquí
perfecto este es el vértice de mi
parábola y por lo tanto ya sabemos cómo
va a mi parábola este es nivel cm y
ahora el máximo ocurre es pues graficar
mi parábola este es el punto más bajo de
mi palabra y si te das cuenta está justo
en medio de los dos puntos que teníamos
los cuales eran la intersección con el
eje de las equis entonces mi parábola se
va a ver más o menos así fíjate bien va
a subir ahora por aquí este es el punto
más pequeño que puede tomar una parábola
y si te das cuenta ya no hay de otra mi
parábola tiene que ser de este estilo ya
no puede ser una palabra que abra hacia
arriba
en esta ocasión mi parábola
abre hacia abajo por todo lo que
acabamos de ver y si le ponemos el valor
a x de 0 entonces interceptamos en el x
la 10 en menos 8 en el punto cero como
menos 8 interceptamos al eje de las 10 y
espero que te haya quedado bastante
claro porque vamos a ver otro ejemplo de
cómo gráfica moss más parábolas así que
déjame cortar esto primero para que no
nos estorbe y tengamos como un pizarrón
nuevo perfecto tenemos una pantalla
nueva y entonces aquí voy a escribir mi
siguiente ejercicio es este que es igual
a 2 x cuadrada y a esto le voy a sumar 6
x ya esto le voy a sumar 4 y ya que la
tengo escrita que es lo primero que hay
que hacer pues claro factorizar esta
expresión para que sea lo más sencilla
de resolver entonces me quedaría y es
igual y tendremos como factor común al
22 que multiplica a x cuadrada más 13 x
+ 2 2 x 3 6 y 2 por 2 son 4 por lo tanto
ya tengo el 2 como factor común y fíjate
la parte de adentro del paréntesis esta
expresión la puedo factorizar esto es lo
mismo que x
que multiplica a x 12 números que
sumados me den 3 y que multiplicados
media en 2 pues es 2 y es 1 esto es muy
claro ahora lo que voy a hacer es buscar
las intersecciones con el eje de las
equis y para eso lo que tengo que hacer
es igualar este cuestión a 0 0 es igual
a 2 que multiplica x + 2 que multiplica
a su vez a x + 1 y recuerda que al hacer
esto lo que estoy buscando son las
intersecciones con el eje de las equis y
bueno 2 x x + 2 x x más uno es igual a
cero si 12 0 o si x + 12 0 o si x + 10
pero dos nunca es 0 12 es 2 por lo tanto
o x + 2 es igual a cero o x más uno es
igual a cero por lo tanto que me
escribió aquí x + 2 es igual a cero o en
su dado caso x más uno es igual a cero y
bueno aquí voy a restar dos de ambos
lados de la ecuación y me va a quedar
que x es igual a menos 2 y de igual
manera que voy a restar menos uno de
ambos lados de la ecuación y me va a
quedar que x es igual a menos uno y ya
con esto encontré las raíces de esta
ecuación y por lo tanto ya tengo que el
punto
- 20 y el punto menos 12 son aquellos
puntos de esta parábola que cumplen que
intersectan al eje de las x y entonces
una vez que ya los tengo los voy a
graficar el menos 20 que es este de aquí
y es más déjeme poner lo mejor con otro
color y voy a hacer también un cambio de
escala porque fíjate con color amarillo
se ve muy mal así que déjenme agarra el
color rosa y mejor voy a decir que este
es el menos uno el menos dos el menos
tres y vamos también para acá uno dos
tres es decir cada dos cuadritos es una
unidad y bueno también para arriba y
para abajo uno dos tres y menos uno
menos 2 y menos 3 y bueno yo tengo el
punto menos 20 y ese es un punto de
donde pasa mi parábola y donde cruza a
lejos de las exportan tolo voy a poner
un color verde y al menos 10 este punto
de aquí también por ahí pasa mi parábola
y bueno habíamos comentado que entonces
para sacar el vértice nos tenemos que
fijar en el punto medio en x de estos
dos valores es decir el valor de x
3 - 2 - 1 / 2 lo cual me da menos 3
entre 2 lo cual es menos 1.5 y si yo
sustituyó aquí en la ecuación original
al menos tres medios o al menos 1.5 que
me va a quedar me va a quedar el valor
de yen pero quién es este valor de bien
va a ser 2 que multiplica a menos tres
medios elevado al cuadrado más 6 que
multiplica al menos tres medios más 4 y
bueno cuando es esto pues vamos a
hacerlo este es el valor de jett delbert
si me queda 2 que multiplica nueve
cuartos menos tres medios elevado al
cuadrado son nueve cuartos y después de
seis entre dos es 33 por menos 3 le va a
dar menos 9 menos 9 y después me queda
más 4 y 2 por 9 cuartos es lo mismo que
nueve medios estás de acuerdo dos se va
con el 4 y me quedan 9 medios menos 9 ya
esto le tengo que sumar 4 menos 94 es lo
mismo que menos 5 de aquí acá esto me da
menos 5 por lo tanto me quedan 9 medios
menos
5 y cuánto es eso pues esto es lo mismo
que menos 10 medios y entonces al final
me va a quedar 9 medios menos 10 medios
es lo mismo que menos un medio y
perfecto ya con esto también tengo el
valor de jeremy bird ese entonces ya
puedo dibujar a mi nivel desde mi vez se
tiene el valor de 1.5 coma menos un
medio es decir este es el punto en donde
está situado mi vértice de mi parábola
así que estoy aquí y lo tengo que poner
justo aquí está perfecto y ya con esto
tengo el bc de mi parábola y me faltaría
saber en donde corta el eje de las guías
pero si yo pongo 0 en x pues me va a
quedar 2 por 0 6 por 0 4 y me queda el
punto 0 4 justo ahí es donde intersecta
al eje de las 10 y ahora sí ya puedo
dibujar mi parábola fíjate bien ahora lo
voy a hacer para acá este lado me queda
un poco feo pero bueno aquí está mi para
volar justo en medio está mi vértice y
entonces ya tengo mi segundo ejercicio
si te das cuenta
no estaba tan difícil como pensábamos
así que vamos a hacer un tercer
ejercicio pues para que todo este
conocimiento se asiente bien aquí en
en nuestro cerebro y sepamos
perfectamente bien cómo resolver
cualquier gráfica de una función
cuadrática entonces ahora tengo menos x
cuadrada más 10 x menos 21 y bueno lo
primero que hay que hacer era factorizar
lo más que se pudiera entonces voy a
factorizar al menos 1 y que me va a
quedar menos 1 que multiplica x cuadrada
menos 10 x más 21 esto es actualizando
este menos 1 porque me gusta más tener a
x cuadrada positiva que tener la
negativa y bueno ahora voy a buscar dos
números que multiplicados me den 21 y
que sumados me den menos 10 y parece ser
que 7 y 37 por 3 21 y sumados me dan
buenos y los pongo negativos me van a
dar menos 10 entonces esto me queda de
la forma menos 1 que multiplica a x
menos 3 que multiplica a su vez a x
menos 7 ya te diste cuenta con la equis
cuadrada positiva es mucho más fácil
factorizar yo así menos 3 x menos siete
me da 21 positivos y menos 3 menos 7 me
da menos 10 y bueno
a continuación recuerda que lo que
tenemos que hacer es sacar las
intersecciones con el eje de las equis y
para eso lo que voy a hacer es que lleva
al casero y
queda 0 es igual a menos 1 por x 3 por x
7 y aquí me queda que x3 es igual a 0 en
su dado caso x 7 es igual a 0 y x menos
3 es igual a cero si x es igual a 3 y x
menos 7 es igual a 0
si x es igual a 7 y llegó néstor ya
tengo mis dos valores en donde se
intersectan el eje de las x en el 3
viene el 7 estamos aquí en el 3 y
estamos aquí en el 7 aquí también te
afecta el eje de las x por lo tanto
tenemos los puntos 30 y 70 y bueno vamos
a sacar el valor del vértice primero que
fijarnos en el valor de x para esto lo
que tengo que hacer es 3 más 7 entre 2
es decir sacar el punto medio lo cual me
da 5 y cuánto vale que en el vértice
pues hay que sustituir este valor en x
aquí en ecuación original y me quedaría
menos 25 más 10 por 5 lo cual me da 50
menos 21 5 por 5 me da 25 por el menos
me da menos 25 10 por 5 medio 50 y esto
menos 21 y aquí me queda menos 25 50 es
25 25 21
4 positivo entonces de todo esto me
queda 4 por lo tanto mi punto del
vértice está en el 5
4 mil veces éste está situado en el 54
déjenme ponerlo por aquí a ver déjame
escribir los 54 es el punto del vértice
y entonces tengo que mirar 5 estamos
aquí y 4 para arriba
2 3 4 estamos aquí y si te das cuenta el
vértice me está quedando arriba de
distintas secciones qué quiere decir eso
nosotros habíamos encontrado para aulas
que abrían hacia abajo sin embargo esta
parábola tiene que abrir hacia arriba
porque si abre hacia abajo entonces el
vértice está situado abajo de los puntos
de intersección y si te das cuenta en
esta ocasión me queda que el verde se
está arriba de mis ejes de intersección
por lo tanto mi parábola abre hacia
arriba y porque abre hacia arriba qué
cosa tan rara no de qué va a depender
que abre hacia arriba o que abre hacia
abajo una parábola déjeme dibujarla un
poco mejor porque no me está quedando va
bien va bien perfecto aquí está mi
parábola y entonces se decía de qué va a
depender que mi parábola abra hacia
arriba
y la respuesta es de este signo menos
que yo tengo aquí si el signo de la
equis cuadrada es positivo entonces mi
parábola va a abrir hacia abajo si el
signo de la equis cuadrada es negativo
entonces mi parábola va a abrir hacia
arriba como en este caso si te das
cuenta tenemos un signo negativo y por
lo tanto cambia la dirección de mi
parábola y bueno si te das cuenta si mi
parábola abre hacia abajo entonces mi
vértice es el punto mínimo de esta
parábola y si mi parábola abre hacia
arriba entonces el vértice va a ser mi
punto máximo y bueno entonces nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo